we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question about priorities
for democrats in the house that came in
take a listen to this i david this is
adam in california now that the
democrats have taken the house my
question is do you think their time is
better spent investigating trump in his
cabinet and pushing out sort of this
legal battle against him or do you think
there are times that are spent working
on bipartisan issue that they can try to
work on together such as infrastructure
or middle-class tax cuts um love you
shows yeah thanks and have a wonderful
day it's a false choice I mean the demo
and chew gum at the same time any
investigation that should happen should
happen you don't say well we would love
to work with Republicans on a tax cut
for the middle class so we're not gonna
do any investigation no if it's if it's
a valuable endeavor then you do it plain
and simple and we'll be talking this
week actually about exactly what should
be the Democratic agenda after they get
sworn in in January of 2019
check out exclusive deals from our
sponsors for David Pakman show viewers
and listeners at david pakman.com slash
deals we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today
ww join pakman.com to become a member
and get access patreon.com slash david
pakman show to become a patron and get
access to the bonus show one one way or
another we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about what's been
happening on the sunday shows for the
last three months we will talk about the
NRA mocking doctors and how doctors have
responded and we we actually already
have more than one 20/20 presidential
candidate on the Democratic side we will
talk about all of that and more on
today's bonus show I'll speak to you
then